Hey everyone, it's Michael Altos and
welcome to the order flows market
analysis for June 27, 2017. The S&Ps
were down uh quite a bit today.
Basically on the back of the news that
the Senate vote on the Obamacare
replacement won't be held until after
the July 4th recess, which basically
just further pushes back the Trump
administration's economic agenda. The
economic data that came out, the
positive spot was the consumer
confidence report, which continues to
hold at very strong levels. And in the
assessment of the current labor market
points to I think solid results for the
June employment report which will come
out on uh July 7, not this week. Uh June
30th is Friday. Um July 7th is is the
first Friday of July. Oil firmed and
we're back above $44. The dollar fell
against the euro. Um even the dollar
index was about 1% lower. So, you know,
that said, let's uh let's jump into the
market first with uh the disclaimer.
This presentation is for educational
andformational purposes only and should
not be considered a solicitation to buy
or sell a futures contract or make any
other type of investment decision.
Futures trading contain substantial risk
and is not for every investor. An
investor could potentially lose all or
more than the initial investment. Risk
capital is money that can be lost
without jeopardizing one's financial
security or lifestyle. Only risk capital
should be used for trading and only
those with sufficient risk capital
should consider trading. Past
performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results. So the
tools that I use in this presentation
are the order flows trader and the delta
scalper.
So let's take a look at the markets.
First market I'll talk about this
morning
um euro currency. Give me a sec. Get the
chart up here.
You know,
again, I I talk about these setups, you
know, every day. Ratio and divergence.
Ratio and divergence. So, you know, what
is a divergence? Divergence occurs when
you have a new or equal
high and a negative delta or new or
equal low and a positive delta. Um, I
take it a step further. I want to see
price action in the bar. I don't want to
just see uh like a green bar market
that's rallying even though you still
have a negative delta at at a new high.
No, I want to see price action in the
bars which giving me an extra an extra
sense of
um extra sense of security, extra sense
of yeah security um in the sense that
you know the market is the price action
in the market is confirming that you
know your your sell signal. You know,
all too often I see people taking
trades, you know, getting short on a
market that's rallying. Well, you know,
if your bar that's signaling, giving you
a signal that the market is is should be
selling off. If that bar can't even
close lower than it opens, it's probably
not going to be a very effective signal.
And, you know, people lose sight of that
because they're so centered on, oh, I
got to take this this trade signal um
without taking it in context of the
market. You that's where they go lost.
So like here you have a divergence. You
got a new high. Got negative delta. You
got the red bar. You got a divergence.
But again, you know, do I like it? Not
really. You know, it's just a
divergence. You know, I'd like to get a
ratio telling me there's price rejection
or price support. You get up here and
you still got a red bar, but it's
positive delta. So it's telling me
partly that maybe maybe the buying is
not over. You know, it may not continue
right in the next bar. May come off a
bit and, you know, rally back up there.
So, whoops. Okay. So, we sell off from
here. This this level. I thought this
was interesting. I was talking about
this in the room today. This move here,
very strong delta, 600, 800. And you're
at your high. You got a very small delta
131, but you got a red bar. Why? You
know, there's selling coming into this
market. You know, in the price action of
the bar is red. Okay. And more
importantly, you're at your high and you
got, you know, decreasing delta. Then
you come off your high. Next bar you got
a ratio which is also bearish. Then you
got a smaller positive delta. So the net
aggressive buying is is drying up and
now you got next bar very strong selling
- 167. Next bar if you're not convinced
yet - 300 in the delta. That's very
strong negative. Even though the bar is
green it's it's small green. It's a
dogee bar almost. Um but it's not a
dogee. But you know again you know it's
it's you know one price level is is the
candle. Um but again you know what what
you're taking out from here is you're
coming up to your
high and you got no more buying. You
know it's very weakened up here 13167
then minus the selling is taking over.
So as you're coming up you got some
strong deltas but then at the turn you
can see how the aggressive buying is
really slowing down and now aggressive
selling is taking over. So at this point
you should be convinced you know when
we're trading 1 13 47 46 this area that
you know selling has taken over and what
happens we sell off from the 47 area
down into you know the mid30s here. Um
eventually we do go
lower start rallying back up get up to
this high up
here. This is a delta scalp we're giving
a sell. This one didn't really work out
that well. Um, next bar, you know, next
bar came right back up on you very fast
and would have stopped you out and then
you're starting to rally up here. Rally,
rally, making new highs, making new
highs. Got a bearish ratio. Zero delta
actually. Um, it's just coincidence that
it landed on zero often times when it
does appear on zero. Nothing, no great
underlying force there. So, don't get uh
too excited when you see it. But then
you get up to this high, you don't have
a divergence. Still got positive delta.
And then you do have a bearish ratio
though. Next bar, negative delta. Next
bar, positive delta. Okay, it's kind of
mixed here. You know, looking for any
signs when you're getting up near a high
that this move can be over. Don't really
see it there. You know, it's not clear.
It's not clear. However, when you get up
here, it's very clear. You got a bearish
ratio. You got a divergence. And what
happens? It's just straight down. I say
straight down. It's more of a it's an
angle down, but you know, you know what
I mean. Um, again, you're seeing some
nice things here. You got a bearish
ratio. So, here's the ratio and
divergence. You got the bearish ratio.
Got some trap traders there. Single
print as well. And you move you
literally you go from 80, you know, down
into the
60s. You know, that that was a every day
I talk about ratios and divergences.
And, you know, that that's just a
perfect a perfect example. Do you see
any other ratios here? No. But you see
divergences. Just cuz you got
divergences doesn't necessarily mean
it's going to work
out. You know, this I thought was
interesting here. This this high tie
with the buying imbalance on a red bar.
U very rarely do you get uh stacked
buying imbalances in a red bar. But you
know this is you know people talk about
people being trapped in the market.
Trapped traders. Trapped traders. You
hear that word every other freaking
video with with certain order flow.
People what you have here are people
buying the breakout looking for the
market to go higher and it's not and now
they're bailing out of their position
and the market goes lower. This is a
great selling opportunity when you see a
bar like this buying imbalances in the
top stack buying imbalance of a red bar
there in the wick. What would really
make this ideal much better is if there
was some selling imbalances here. But
this by itself is is very negative and
you know the market sells off quite a
bit here. Then comes down delta scalper
given a buy up to new
highs and and that was it. I mean those
are some nice moves there. The big move
was obviously the ratio and divergence.
The one with the delta earlier was you
know it takes some thinking to to really
understand it and and see it. But again,
you know, if once you understand, once
you're watching what happens in the
market, you know, things like this
become very, very
clear. Okay, so the next market I talk
about is the yen. Yen, you kind of
pissed me off a little bit this morning
actually. So, you've got, you know,
failed diver uh failed delta sculper
here in the sense that, you know, it's
not going to give you, you shouldn't be
taking this trade. It's the um it's a
red bar and you're getting a buy signal,
right? You should be taking buy signals
on green bars, not on red bars. But
anyway, you get um failed divergence
here at this uh 923 bar with the ratio
136. Another delta scalper buy that you
wouldn't be taking. Another failed
divergence here um at the low of
1012 coming down into the
lows. You got this uh delta scalper.
Give it a buy. You got a ratio, bullish
ratio. You got a
divergence. Yeah, I like that.
Unfortunately, it came down and made a
new low by two ticks. got another
divergence and then the rally started,
you know, boom, right up in here. Um,
you know, it's just unfortunate that you
made a new low by two ticks before you
got the move, but you know, sometimes
the market hasn't found its low. Um, but
you did get another redemption in here.
You got Delta Scalper giving a buy here
just above the
low. This is actually the volatile
transition in here as well. That's what
this yellow sign is. Rallies up. Then
boom, you get a delta scalper sell about
10 minutes later. you know, market comes
off. Delta surge here. This is Delta
Surge giving you a buy signal and you
know, it was just off to the races
there. Delta Scoper. This one didn't
work out here. This is already about
this is just before 3:00 in the
afternoon, 2:50. Um, so again, you you
really think twice about trading um
currencies after after 2
p.m. Uh, basically that's when the the
deal dealers in New York closed their
books for the day is 2
p.m. So, you know, why should you be
messing around in the currency futures
then? Okay, bonds. Bonds are just under
pressure all day. Um, starting about
3:00 in the
morning, you know, 9:00 a.m. London
time, we hit our high and got Delta
Scalper, right off the high, Delta
Scalper, and big stacked imbalance here.
Just four price levels on a on a on a
four range chart. So, you only got five
five price levels, but, you know,
stacked imbalance is pretty much the
entire bar except for this one lot that
traded here. And it's literally under
pressure. very very few buying
opportunities or reasons to be buying
off your lows. You came down here, you
had the ratio and divergence just went
sideways on you, but it came right back
with the next bars as a as a bearish
ratio again, which is not a good sign.
Usually when you get
um a buy signal and the next bar has a
bearish signal, it's not going to work
out. Um that's very high percentage of
failure that's going to work out. Um,
I'm not a particular type of trader
that, you know, I get long here, then I
got a bearish signal like I get short.
No, you know, I I I wait for another uh
another reason to be getting
short. This bar here, I found this bar,
this 914 bar, I thought it was going to
be very bearish, actually.
And you didn't get the move cuz in the
next bar, I got a bullish ratio and a
divergence and the delta scalper. I was
really excited here at this at this low
that the market go higher and it started
out it started going higher here. Um got
all the way back to 156 and then boom
selling just came right back in. So you
know I found this bar to be bearish
although I don't like it in the place
that it is. Okay. I would prefer this
type of bar um to be you know at a swing
high. I I could show you an example
where it was at a swing high, something
very similar to this and the market sold
off. But, you know, it's coming right at
your low of the day. So, you know, while
there are bars that I do like, you know,
the way the order flow looks in it, you
know, you got to take it in context.
Where do you want it to happen? Do you
want it to be happening on the low if
you're getting short or do you want it
to be happening after the market just
bounced up and rallied a bit, then you
get this type of bar, then look for the
market to sell off. So, let me find let
me just find that other one. um because
it it's it's excellent um discussion.
Okay, so here it is. It's in the buns.
Um let me just put these two charts side
by side so you can see it, understand
what I'm talking about.
So okay, so buns, right? We had our low
here at 502. You can see it right down
here. It's it's a ratio no divergence.
Then you rally up from this low which is
15450. We get all the way up to 64. So
about a or 65. So about 15 tick rally.
Okay. And then you got a buying
imbalance here. Selling imbalance.
Selling imbalance. Selling imbalance.
Very thin volume here. So what the
market is doing? Market's rallying.
People are getting excited. You got
buying imbalance in the bar before it
coming up here thinking, hey, you know,
we're rallying off this low. Everyone's
coming in buying at this level. They
turn it bid. They're still buying. All
of a sudden, you got a big seller comes
in, wax this bid, wax these bids down.
Very little buying. You know, people,
very few buyers aggressively lifting the
offer, right? And then what happens is
the market sells off down to the lows,
new lows.
Now, put that next to this this bond.
Okay, this bond, you know, we had been
selling off since 3:00 in the morning,
you know, from above, you know, from
where 157 or I can't remember what the
high
was, you know, 15706 was the high. And
right after the high at above 157, you
get in the sell signal. Now, market
sells off, sells off. you get down here,
you're trading below 156. So, you know,
a full point lower and you get the same
type of bar. You get some buyers coming
in here thinking, hey, you know, buying
got that buying imbalance in the second
level. Maybe you everyone's thinking,
hey, this is the low. Let's start buying
it. And selling just comes right back
in. They turn it bid and it just gets
whacked, whacked, whacked. Very little
trade on the offer. You got imbalance,
imbalance, imbalance. So, you got that
buying imbalance in the second spot.
selling imbalance opposite it and then
selling balances below it just like you
have here in the
buns. But what's the difference is this
one's coming up off a
rally and then you're getting it. It's a
better to me it's a better signal. Um
now I I know some people are going to
say well you can still take it as a
short because obviously the market did
go lower. Yeah, you can.
But what happens is you run right into
this very bullish signal right here.
Delta um positive delta here. You've
got, you know, bullish ratio delta
scalper. Market just goes sideways and
then sells off much later. But, you
know, it it's still a bearish bar. But I
rather take, you know, bearish
signals after a rally than bearish
signals as you're pounding into new
lows, especially after you've already
made a monster move. You know, from 157
down to 156, you know, is a very strong
move in the bonds. But, um, again, you
know, those are two bars that are very
similar. You know, where would you
rather take it in in context? I mean,
yeah, you can take this bar as a short,
look for the bar to go lower, but if you
run into a bullish sign, I mean, just as
any anything, um, you know, you're going
to get caught out and you have to you
probably want to get out of your
position. But anyway, you know, I'm
just, you know, I I just prefer to take
those those trades structurally at, you
know, if I'm getting short, I I just
prefer to get short after a rally rather
than get short after a big a big a big
sell-off.
Um anyway, just continue. Um Delta
Scalper failed there. Got a divergence
that
failed. Nothing on this low really
telling you to to get long. Come up
here. Delta Scalper giving you a buy.
This is 2:00 again. It's it's right on
the the cash close. Market does sell off
uh you know, the next couple bars
before reopening and coming back up to
where we are. The five year is very
similar. I felt um let me just find the
five-year chart
here again. You know, you got that same
I think on this one at that 3 in the
morning, you did have the ratio and
divergence though that you didn't have
in the bonds. So, you got the divergence
here. You got the ratio in the next bar
zero. You got the stacked imbalance as
well. And then the market just boom sold
off all all morning. very similar delta
uh ratio and divergence here didn't work
out you know failed divergence here at
1969 failed divergence here then you
came down in here I remember getting a
little bit excited I love buying and
balances right off the low and it just
proceeded to go sideways hit the low
once twice three times before putting in
a little half-hearted rally here going
into the close I mean I I wouldn't
consider this a great trading victory
But I do like buying balances off the
low and this
was this gave you a chance to get
something out of the
day. Now
S&Ps S&Ps again, you know, big down day,
but I did feel there
were there were some signs early that
you could possibly have a down day. Um,
but after the signs came out, the market
did rally. Let me I can't seem to find
my chart now.
Okay. So, I'll just talk about the signs
early that I felt that the market can
can sell
off but then you know as as I was I was
in it was in the room talking about it
and then the market rallied up towards
the highs but it came in here. Okay. So,
cash opened you know 8:30 here. It's
kind of quiet
morning then the market started selling
off. This is 830 cash
open. Boom. You got divergence that
failed. Divergence that failed. Another
divergence. Well, I I don't want to say
these failed, but again, you know, these
are divergences with with nothing there.
Um, you know, then it just started
rallying, rallying, rallying. And I I
was going to at this point, I mean, I
did have this buy and balance off this
low, which, you know, is bullish for me.
But what I was really looking for when I
say these divergences that failed,
honestly, what I was looking for, I was
I was getting ahead of myself is these
hadn't failed yet. But what I was
looking for was this market to sort of
bounce up like this, you know, maybe
rally a couple points and come back into
these lows. That's why I say failed. I
mean later in the day they failed but at
this point they hadn't failed because
what I was looking for was you know this
market to you know some selling to come
in and start pushing the market lower
you know I looking for some imbalances
here around the 24 29 and a quarter area
29 level and below it I was looking for
some some aggressive selling to come in
but it wasn't coming in um and in the
end the market just you know started
rallying started rallying we started
getting up near the close sorry up near
the high of the
day hanging around the opening price
rotating around. You know, news started
coming out that the vote was uh not
going to happen and then the market
started selling off and came down here
made made new lows. No divergence yet.
Still negative
delta and then boom, you know, you get
the selling imbalances, you know, 28 and
1/2, 28 3/4 or sorry, 28 and 1/2, 28 and
a quarter, 28. then it just, you know,
it just gets pounded down lower. So, you
know, I was looking at the market later.
I I had to my kids made a mess. I had to
clean it up. But, um, I remember
thinking, "Oh, now we finally got that
low." You know, we finally coming under
pressure, but by that time is as well
well after the fact. I mean, I would
have liked that move to come in a little
bit early um to sort of sort of
vindicate
me. But, you know, I mean, are there any
other signals? I mean, yeah. I mean,
Delta Scalper, of course, you got a lot
of um some trading signals. You know,
you got a sell there. You got a buy here
that, you know, worked out a little bit.
This buy didn't work out right ahead of
the cash close. You even going into the
cash close, you're still making new
lows, new
lows. And, you know, in the evening
session right now, we are just um we're
just a little bit above our lows for the
day, you know, on the daily chart.
on the daily chart, you hit the big big
down candle right
here. But, you know, the move didn't
happen
until until a little bit later. I mean,
it was it was rallying, you know, up at
about 10:00 or up up um you know, closer
to the high than to the low. But once it
started coming to that low, it just got
pounded.
But I did sort of feel I say I hate to
use the term feel, but you know when
when you've been around the markets long
enough, you can you're sort of
anticipating things. I mean that's not
scientific and not something that could
be bottled up and shared with other
people. But you know the other thing
that I was looking at was this volume
profile. You had been putting in, you
know, lower point of control, you know,
when you're at trading at this time, you
know, 845, 850. You had your point of
control up here earlier. I mean we did
come back up obviously put it up there
but um then later you had a you know the
lower point of control and so you
started getting point of controls going
lower at this at this point but um you
know that was a sign to me that I was
trying to put it together with these
failed well the like I said these two
weren't failed imbalances until later in
the day but I was sort of trying to
looking for the selloff to come in here
um but eventually it rallied I said it
rallied back up to the 36 six level, but
I was looking for it to sort of come
back in here relatively soon just after
9:00. It didn't. It didn't. Um, but if
it did, you know, then yeah, I would
have been looking to I would been
looking for the market to head a lot
lower. Uh, let me just see if I can find
the 10 range chart
here. Excuse me.
Okay, so now this is how the 10 range
looks. You know, after you did have a a
decent buy signal here. Um, but again,
you know, we came into that low. You got
that divergence here. Next bar, you got
a delta scalper.
You know, eventually it got up there. It
just sort of it took a long way to get
up there. Um, you know, you had this
stack buying imbalance
here. You know, I was thinking, you
know, hey, we got this buying imbalance
at this time. It was sort of, you know,
right on the upper end of the value
area. Um, and say we did rally. We got
up to 37 before, you know, everything
just turned around on you and the
selling came in here and, you know, just
went lower, lower, lower. stack selling
a balance there just to you know add
fuel to the fire all negative deltas um
on this move here and you're at your
high up here you know delta at one point
is very strong I remember looking at
this positive delta 9,000 ended up at at
just 3,000 so you know it gave back
6,000 which is which is important you
know then here very strong negative
delta 10,000 you know when I see
negative delta of 10,000 on a bar on the
10 range chart to me it's you know, sell
it. You know, no questions asked, sell
it. And, you know, you could be selling
it anywhere here at 31, 30 and a half,
30 even. And it's it's a nice 10 point
say 10point move. But, you know, at
least five points could have got out of
it. Um, uh, again, you know, delta,
watch it. you know, when numbers are
just
gigantic. Um, you know, it's it's a sign
that someone's, you know, other time
frame traders are really getting active
in there and just dominating this
market. You know, when I see negative
delta of 10,000, I don't think it's a
bunch of day traders coming in there. It
it takes real solid money to sell the
out of the market like that. And
the market sold off brilliantly.
Brilliantly.
Okay, so uh thanks everyone for watching
this video. Be sure to subscribe to my
YouTube channel to be alerted to when I
post new videos. And to learn more about
the trading software I use in this
presentation and how you can profit from
Orderflow, visit my website,
orderflows.com. And thank you. Bye-bye.